hi my name is Katie I attended the four
day training course for my seeing as
p.m. my husband also said it for the
capm that's ended up going to do our PMP
I found the course very very useful very
informative i was looking for a
challenge and I think I got what if I
can't wait to go home and go through the
material I'm very excited I think the
material that was provided was very
clear concise and of course was the
atmosphere was very informal which I
really liked I didn't like that it was
so structured and you just SAT there
dread two slides a lot of feedback
one-on-one lot of participation amongst
everybody which was great I would highly
recommend it to my colleagues thank you
very much hi my name's Rainer kind of
course with my wife I started initially
coming here for the capm but she said
that it will be probably pursuing the
EMP the information there's a lot of
information but the way that it's taught
through the course with the interactions
and the questions and answers clear
very clear concise and she said when we
go home and study together as our empty
together should make it enjoyable I
would either recommend this for other
people would take the courses